Hello, everybody. It's Dr. Kevin Cutters, but to another episode of holistic health
hour, where we do our best to answer your questions. Remember, if you have questions,
you can add them to the chat, which I better open the chat right now. If you get that
going, connect the chat. So feel free to chat in your questions, or if you want to have a
better chance of your question, get it answered. Go to holistichealthhour.com, and you
can put your question in beforehand. And that's your best chance to get the question answered.
But feel free to chat in your questions. Also, we're invited to go to our website CuttersClinic.com,
where you'll find out that there are a lot of questions already answered. Many videos go along
with those questions that are blog posts with a really nice search app that can search for those
questions. But without further ado, let's get on to our questions.
First question is, will some research details on tumors? I came across an article that stated that
due to the presence of co-lead in eggs, it can cause prostate cancer. Yet, we are instructed that
co-lead is a necessary nutrient for autism sufferers. What about co-lead in eggs causing prostate cancer?
I always thought that it would be caused for grade-bed chickens, and that eggs for grass-bed
chickens would be safe. Here's the link to an article I found. While I would agree that there
has been some research that co-lead, that egg consumption, let's say that, that egg consumption
can be linked to increase in prostate cancer and some other cancers.
I question the research quite honestly. If you understand the co-lead pathway, so co-lead goes
into your cells through a transporter in the cell membrane, and then it is converted to multiple
things, and it's necessary for a lot of different things. It's converted to baitane, which is tri-metho
glycine, and then from that, that helps with what's called the botanine cycle. If anybody's ever
had their genetics done, or if you want to learn more about the botanine cycle, the importance of that,
and how you convert B12 to cobala-mead, and how you use cobala-mead at the M-T, M-M-T pathway, and
the pathways that help convert homocysteine, and get rid of homocysteine, that's part of the
M-T-I-D cycle. So co-lead is a helper in that cycle, and it's dependent upon co-lead. Co-lead also
in the cell can convert to phosphatidyl co-lead, which is an absolute essential fact that helps with
cell membrane production, and with brain function completely, and with neural function,
and then also co-lead converts to aceto-co-lead, which is a neurotransmitter. So co-lead is a necessary
nutrient in our body. So when you see these studies that say eggs are bad for prostate cancer patients
and things, the thing that is missing in this study is number one, other factors. There's
other factors. When you talk about dietary factors with cancer, they're ignored any other factors
that whatever that person is going to, I think there was a study that this person who asked the
question is referred to show that eating more than three eggs a week increased prostate cancer,
yeah, chances have been, interests have been. Well there's just so many variables that go on in
a study like that that differences in lifestyle can make. Not to mention what you what you mentioned,
what is the quality of eggs, if it even is eggs that this that a person is eating. Are they
grasped eggs? Are they eggs that are fed with foods that have all sorts of chemicals, and in them
grains that are GMO grains, is that an issue? Then it was just hypothesized that it was co-lead.
Now I can see where co-lead, excess co-lead could be an issue with people that have
serious issues with pain-creatic function, because in order for co-lead to break down to function
in the methyonine pathway, it needs an enzyme and deficiency in that enzyme could cause issues.
You also have issues co-lead in order to break down the phosphatidal co-lead,
needs energy needs, it's dependent on different gene pathways and such
so there could be an issue with break down of any nutrient, but I'm a little bit sus
of the studies that showed eggs as a culprit in cancer. It all are tested over the years with
causes of cancer. We do kinesiology testing, cheek swab testing for pieces of diet with cancer.
Egg has never come up. I will say egg can be the protein in eggs. A person can develop antibodies
again, so if they have major gut issues and leaky gut problems, it's easy to develop antibodies to
even good foods, so proteins that are in foods that are good for us, including eggs, you can develop
antibodies. You can have antibodies to the protein in eggs, and then when you eat eggs, if you do have
those antibodies, you will cause a inflammatory reaction of the gut. So enough to say that eggs are
great for everyone, if you do notice any issues with eggs, or if you do have inflammatory conditions,
getting a food sensitivity panel that will test for IgG and IgA reactions, antibodies to eggs,
would be in order to be a smart thing to test for. But as far as eggs be a cause of cancer,
I'm a little sus of that study, and I don't know that it's colline. I really struggle with that.
You know, you look at a pathway that colline breaks out, it's called the Metabolic Sanctuary,
it's called the Kennedy Pathway, so you can look up that pathway, and there can be different
gene issues that it could possibly be producing too much methionine, and it's actually the methionine
that is feeding the cancer. There's different thoughts about that, but I don't even know
that the study is balanced, so you're going to be careful with some of the studies that you're reading.
Next part of that question, were what about head tubers? Can eating eggs cause or exacerbate
head tubers? Again, we've answered that question. I don't think eggs are an issue. If you really want
to know for your specific cancer and have us test you, then doing cheek swab testing would be really
in a order to see what diet could be feeding your cancer, so if you read anything about, you know,
what we believe about a diet in cancer, I don't think that there's a one size fits all with cancer,
the other certain things that generally you'd want to stay away from that I have addressed on
other questions like dairy and things because there's both factors in it. But as far as specifically
what could be dietarily feeding a person's cancer, what is that fuel source of that cancer?
The only way that I know to get specific with it is that our cheek swab testing,
and you can find more information on that on our website colorsclinic.com.
Next question, I was diagnosed with Lyme disease in several colon infections several years ago.
I've done several rounds of a few different antibiotics over a period of two years. I most likely have
been in phase three live for a while, so obviously this person is reading our information on Lyme because
I came up with that phase three, phase three Lyme is when you're in an autoimmune condition, so
you may not even have a presence of any active antigen feeding, um, living organism,
the verilya, the colon infections may not even be physically present in that person's body,
anymore, but what those things have done is sparked the production of self-antivities. So the
person has antibodies to self-tissue. That is they have an autoimmune disease. That's what's called
phase three Lyme. I've done many supplements in Holyopathics over the years. Now I know not to take
the immune boosted ones, so of course you don't take immune boosted supplements at all if you have
an autoimmune disease because when you stimulate your immune system, if you have antibodies to
self-tissue, what are you going to do? You're going to kill that which you have antibodies against
first, which is yourself. I've done daily rife treatments for six months in Infrared Sonia.
I've eaten a clean organic gluten, a dairy-free diet for years. I've done bowel, kidney,
and liver cleanses along with colonics. I've done a lot of things over the years. I've not seen
much improvement and seem to be getting worse. The live doctor I was seeing and working with
in Wisconsin retired. My main symptoms are
raging eggs in arms and legs, joint pain in these brain fog, lack of energy, occasional sensitive
skin. What would you suggest? So when you have pain in your extremities that tends to move around
when you have brain fog, when you have lack of energy, sensitivity in your skin that tends to
move around. It's not like I have sensitivity at this one spot right here between my thumb and my
finger, and I have loss of sensitivity there. Then you know it's probably a peripheral nerve issue,
damage the peripheral nerve that feeds that area right there. When it moves around, you have this
weird sensitivity of your skin that's different. It's not constant. It can be in different spaces,
and such, along with these other symptoms, it's more important. Most likely you're dealing with
inflammation that's in the brain itself. If you have damage in the brain, if you have inflammation
that's in the brain, it's going to affect where those neurons are going, or it's going to affect.
So if I have in the pride alone of my brain, that's my sensory part of the brain. You know,
left and right pride alums. Your left pride alone controls the sensory is getting
communication with the sensory on the right side of the body, the vice versa. If I have inflammation
in my right pride alone today, then I could have sensory issues in my left side of my body.
Hey, hot and cold sensation. We're tingling. You know, all sorts of weird, any type of sensory issues.
So it's very common that post-line disease, post-vaccine injury, post-heavy mental toxicity,
post-concussion, that we end up with inflammation in the brain. An inflammation in the brain,
long-term could lead to damage to the brain's immune system called the microglial cells.
That's called microglial private. At worst case scenario, you could end up developing antibodies
to neural tissue. So you can't really test for microglial private that really has to do with a
coordination of subjective findings, but you can test for auto-antivities to neural tissue.
That is a Cyrex Array 7x test. So that's what I would recommend for a person. They came to me with
this condition. I'd say, let's get a Cyrex Array 7x. Also, I probably get a Cyrex Array 5 because
that test for other antibodies. Again, in a person's, I suspect reading your information that I have
an autoimmune disease. I suspect that I'm in phase 3 live. Okay, but what antibodies do you have?
What self-antivities are dealing with? Because that's how you would work up a treatment plan
for the person. If the person has no neurological antibodies, but let's say they have anti-body,
you have rheumatoid factor or something. Okay, so you're at an early stage of rheumatoid arthritis,
then you're going to be looking for different triggers that are going to be affecting that,
which may be very different than what could be affecting the rheological antibodies. So the first
thing would be to get a more proper diagnosis. And that would be to get some antibody testing.
So I'd suggest getting a Cyrex Array 5 and a Cyrex Array 7x. If those are all cleaned,
that would be a really good thing. And that would tell us that we could dial it back a little bit
that we're dealing with. It doesn't mean you still still have horrible symptoms, but it's probably
due to microglial primate. I do have a good video on that. I mentioned that multiple times
in the holistic health hour. If you go to our website cuttersclinic.com and you search
Bureau inflammation. Bureau inflammation. You'll see a video. It's about a half hour long video
on microglial primate. And it does go through some care options with that too. I maybe start with that.
And I suspect you're probably on one of our courses, unless you've just read my books.
So you can do to understand autoimmune disease, but I highly recommend our autoimmune
product disease. Okay, questions from the chat. Any remedy for birding mouth symptoms? This was
a question that came in last week on the chat as well. Birding mouth symptoms and birding mouth
syndrome. Again, you would be right in line. It's most likely an autoimmune condition. It can be
from an issue with chronicliance. It can be from wound deficiencies. You've got to dig into it.
We need to hold this with everybody, but you've got to find a practitioner. You contact us at
scheduler case review with me or find a local practitioner if you're more
active to feel comfort with that and have somebody that will dig to find causes. So most of the time
people get frustrated because they go into their GP and they have a symptom like the questions
you guys are asking. And then, you know, maybe they'll run a CBC and a complete metabolic panel and
it's within most of them are within normal lab ranges. And they say, we know that what's wrong with
you called a psychologist. Very unfortunate. It's very, you know, that's why you're seeking alternative
care. You need to find a functional medicine doctor that doesn't do something similar. It's not
just, oh, we're going to throw this supplement at it or just supplement at it, but they're going
to dig to find some causes. So that's through going through kind of what we're talking about on these
calls, a pattern of different understanding differential diagnosis. So you're going, well, what could
it be? So you're thinking, oh, you got to find a practitioner that once he's willing to put on a
Sherlock Holmes hat and go, well, what could this be? Okay, Marty Melcidro could it be a product
issue? Sure, it could be. So this person have, you know, something as simple as a sensitivity to
something they're putting to their mouth like toothpaste or something. Could they have a sensitivity
to the mercury that's in their fillings? Could they have a sensitivity to, no, there's there's just
a plethora of different things that you want to test for. So digging to that cause there's
again, bottom line, there's always a cause and you have to dig to find out what that causes.
Next question for a Facebook user, is there a test brand you recommend over others for food allergies?
I prefer, highly prefer the Syrex lamb, C-Y-R-E-X. If you're one of our course members,
you, which our courses are 50 bucks, you guys right now, but you could order labs through the course.
But we do not have any up price for our labs. So we don't make one penny off our lab. So you
you could order the, for your course member, you could order a lab through the course,
and then if you want to go over it then you have to pay to talk to me to go over it. The Syrex
10 lab, the Syrex array 10 is the food sensitivity panel. But that's assumed that the person is
already gluten free, because it doesn't test for all the gliated peptides. So take a step back
to understand that. So gliated is the protein in gluten. But the protein in gluten, gliated,
is a very long chain protein. So a protein is a chain of amino acids, a sequence of amino acids.
That's what a protein is. I don't remember how many amino acids are in gliated, but it's,
well over 100. And then when you eat that gliated, that gluten, that bread that you're eating,
that gliated protein gets broken down through enzymes. So you have enzymes secreted by your
pancreas that basically act like scissors and cut off that protein. So if you think of that
chain of amino acids, kind of like a pearl necklace. So it's this necklace with 150 different
pearls on it. It's cutting the enzymes, or cutting up that pearl necklace in the sections.
Well, a section of a protein is called a peptide. So you could have a 15 chain peptide, a 27 chain
peptide, a 10 chain peptide. And you shouldn't have any of these peptides get across. They should
all be too big to get across your gut border, unless there are only two amino acids long or smaller.
So ultimately, every protein that you eat in a perfect world, we wouldn't have food sensitivities,
because if we didn't have any gut damage, the proteins that we eat would get broken down
to amino acids. Now they're not recognized as gliated, or gluten, or dairy, or egg, or anything else.
They're just amino acids. So then those amino acids, single amino acids get absorbed across the
gut border. Then your body uses those amino acids to create enzymes, to create other proteins,
to create whatever that cell needs for that cell to function. So our cells use amino acids. They're
not using peptides, nor are they using proteins from food sources. We are supposed to eat food.
It's supposed to break down into amino acids. We absorb the amino acids that are cells,
use those amino acids to make the correct proteins, the correct enzymes, from those amino acids that
we need to function. Problem is, is when we have damaged gut walls, we have things get across the gut
wall that are larger than two amino acids bonded together for the diet peptide. They're larger peptides,
or they're full proteins. Some of the people will, some people have contact with me and go,
although I've had a food sensitive test before, and I'm not sensitive to gluten. Well, let me look
at the test. Well, it's only a gliated test. Well, gliated is this hundred-chain amino acid. You have
to have a pretty darn damaged gut for that size of amino acid to get across the gut wall for your
body to make antibodies against, for you then to show positive antibodies against gliated
as an intact protein. So then we, if that was the case, we know you have a really bad damaged
gut. Most of the time you have antibodies against the peptides. So there's not very many labs that will
test for the gliated peptides. So that's why I recommend the Syrex labs. So if you go, hey, I'm already
gluten-free already. I just need to see what other foods that I had sensitive against. Well,
then I'd say do the Syrex array 10. But if the person's like, well, I'm gluten-free, but I know I've
got issues, then you got to start with the Syrex array 3, and then go to the Syrex array 4, and then
to the Syrex array 10. And they do have a bundle package where you can do all of those together.
Because many times the person won't go gluten-free unless you can prove that they have antibodies
to peptides. It proved that, listen, every time you eat this, you start to fire. If you're
got, you need to deal with that. You need to call that out. So that's why you need to do that. So Syrex
tests for those different peptides. So some people will go on, you know, this other lab is much less
expensive. So I'd rather do that once much less expensive for a reason. So if you really want to get
better and you really want to dig into your health, then you've got to spend a little bit more
and get good labs done. Otherwise, you're not going to get good answers. If you don't get good answers,
you're going to be very frustrated. You're going to have questions like some of the people here do,
like I've been dealing with this for X amount of years and nobody could figure me out. But maybe nobody
could figure out because they're not doing the right tests. So again, if you don't ask the right
questions, you're not going to get the right answers. Okay, next question. I've recently seen
videos and read a few articles discouraging eating rice and oatmeal for a variety of health reasons.
What are your thoughts? Well, I would agree. I mean, rice, I mean, you could find a lot of data that
rice contains a lot of heavy metals. You could find a lot of data that even organic rice contains
heavy metals and even organic oatmeal contains issues. Also, oatmeal can be a cross-contaminated
or gluten can be cross-contaminated with gluten because of where it's milled out the same mill. So
if you have a gluten sensitivity, we need a gluten-created peptide sensitivity and you're eating regular
oatmeal, that could be an issue, oatmeal that isn't organic is probably laden with GMOs,
which is the number one cause of damaged cuts. So there's a lot of things that can be
concerns with any types of grains that not for everybody, but you have to be aware of those
concerns and that's where getting tested for antibodies for those things. But even if you don't have
antibodies for rice, if you don't have any antibodies for gluten and oatmeal and everything,
you do have to be aware that you have to eat as clean of these foods as possible. So if you're
just going to your local coffee shop and getting a oatmeal cup, it's probably not organic.
Therefore, it's laden with GMOs, so it is going to damage your gut big time.
EDGMO food is equivalent to taking it admiotic, and that's what it does to your gut, so it could be very
damaging. Okay, what is the, let me get us that question. I think so. So next, what is the best
approach for a nickel allergy contact dermatitis with chronic allergies right across the nutritious
food spectrum? Okay, I don't think anybody has a nickel allergy. So let's address that first. Can you
have a sensitivity to nickel? Yes, but it is usually because you have a toxicity to nickel. So
nickel is a heavy metal. That's what it would be considered from a functional medicine perspective.
I've had people with nickel issues because they had a nickel plate. So I remember
one patient years ago had a nickel plate in his face because he was at a motorcycle accident or
something like that. He had chronic headaches. We tested it with kinesiology. He had nickel toxicity.
And there's really, I don't remember what we did for him. I don't think we helped him,
because you know, there's no, you can't keylate that out if you got a, you know, seven ounce plate
of nickel in your body. Yeah, that's very discouraging. So I, you know, you'll really have to be careful
when you do medical procedures that are putting things in your body that could be, that potential
to come very toxic. So, yeah, you can have a nickel toxicity and not have, you know, some
plate of nickel, metal plate in your body either. You can have heavy metal toxicity due to exposure.
You got it in a pool. You got it in, you know, some chemical, some pesticide or something. A lot of
pesticides have arsenic or pesticides have other heavy metals in them. That's how they work.
And you're exposed to those things. I've had, I have one person that had lead and it's very
serious, a little bit of toxicity. And he worked at an airlines. It was drilling in a little bit of
aircrafts, you know, for his job eight hours a day. He ended up having to go to bail and get
an EDTA IVs. He was so, he was so still. But, so heavy metal toxicity is real and it is something
that, that a lot of people need to address. I don't think it's an allergy, but it's a toxicity
and over exposure of it can cause allergic type reactions. Certainly can cause rashes, can cause
headaches, can cause all sorts of different things. It can cause damage to the gut, which leads
this second half of this question with chronic allergies right across the nutrition, the nutritional
food spectrum. So when a person does a food test, like we were talking about, like a Syrix array 10,
and it becomes, you know, so they have the Syrix, the way that lab reads it is they have a
column in green, which we do. They have it in those antibodies. Yellow, which you have, you know,
higher quantity of those that normal in red, which is very out of range. But a person has,
when you do that tested, you know, 70% of the food is on the red and yellow spectrum. That means that
that means that they have antibodies to those foods, but it really means that they have
a very damaged gut. So, so a damaged gut, what's that? Leaky gut syndrome. What's that? That means
you have permeability of the gut. Your cells and your gut are supposed to be, you know, tight
together. And that junction of those two cells in the gut are those are epithelial cells are
formed, what's called a tight junction. Yes, and it's on us who are not very creative in how they
name that. But it's called a tight junction. But when that tight junction is damaged, and what damage
is it? Chemicals, toxicities, poisons, GMO foods, use of antibiotics, use of, you know, exposure to
consuming dyes of colorings, you know, chemicals in our food. I mean, you name it. Then that
tight junction gets damaged, but that's what's called leaky gut. So things get across the gut that
shouldn't get across the gut, and when things get across the gut that shouldn't get across the gut.
Remember, you have two ways to get rid of bad things in your body. You either kill it through the
immune response, or you have to detoxify it. So when toxins get across the body, they have to be detoxed
through the liver, and the kidneys through phase one, two, three, and then what I've labeled four,
five, six, have to get out of the body. And in doing so, that's how you get rid of chemicals,
heavy metals like we were talking about poisons. But when foods get across in forms that should never
have got across, which we're speaking about before, like a larger peptide should never have got
across the gut border, the immune system can react, and the immune system is basically like what in
the world is this? Let's make an antibiotic in order to kill it. Well, can you ever kill a food
peptide? No, it's not a living organism. So if you have antibodies to peptides, what it's going
to do is every time you eat that food again, you're just going to cause this inflammatory response.
And when you cause that another inflammatory response, that's another way that you cause damage to
the gut. So it's just this cycle, it's this negative cycle that person, let's say, use glutinous
in a sample. They have antibodies to gluten or gluten peptides. Every time they eat it,
they cause more inflammation, it causes more damage. And now they have antibodies to protein,
dairy proteins. Now they have to continue to eat it and continue to develop antibodies to other foods
and more foods and more foods and continue to have more damage. You have to break that cycle,
so you have to start, if all you do when you do a food sensitivity panel is you stop eating that food.
You're missing the whole point. You have to stop eating the food because if you don't stop eating the
food, you're just going to continue that negative cycle of inflammation every time you eat that food.
But you have to heal the gut. If you're not taking different nutrition to help heal the gut,
then you're never getting better. So all you're going to do is you're going to eliminate, let's say
all the foods on the bad part, and then you retested three to six months. And now you have antibodies
to the foods that you were eating the last three to six months because you never healed the gut.
So you have to really work out healing the gut. It's a process, it takes time, it's not for the
faith of heart, but if you aren't willing to do it, then don't complain about it. Sorry, but that's
just the way it is. So proper testing, get proper testing done. I know what, you know, where the
damage is, what you have, truly have sensitivities to eliminate those foods, and then you start
doing things that are going to help heal that gut border, help improve those tight junctions,
help stop this inflammatory process and break that negative cycle in order for you to get better.
So I really rock a science. It's just a matter of doing the proper testing, fighting out what's
causing inflammation, fighting out what the triggers are, getting rid of those, calling things down,
using some things to help calm the inflammation down, and start healing. It's a process.
So I go through a lot of this in agonizing detail in our courses, and I have multiple videos on a lot
of these different things about when you have an autoimmune disease, how do you find your triggers?
How do you find the thing that's causing inflammation? If I have microglial priming, what do you do to
call that down? What are the steps to do with that? You know, when I try to break it down into baby
steps so that you don't get overwhelmed, but that's the whole idea of the courses. It has a lot
of education. I think the more you know, the better off you're going to be in a lot of different ways,
the more you're going to don't want to do. And I think there's benefit to knowing more so that you
don't get duped by some of these Instagram and Facebook posts that and practitioners that try to
oversimplify, and then all you need to do is take this supplement, or that supplement, and then
you get very discouraged because it didn't work. So, and the things that work, it's easy to get
bumped down and get discouraged. Okay. Next question. All attempts over half of their lifetime,
75 now, have failed to correct chronic fatigue. I know it's fighting. See,
of course, it didn't have done nothing. No indications of any infectious disease that's like
only clue I have is that my deep fatigue is very seasonal, and it's at its worst right now mid-June.
Thought I was onto something thinking that spring was allergy season, and nitric oxide production
might be impeding in the days of the nasal passages, daily dose of fermented beet powder,
in other nitric oxide producers seem to help at first, but that it didn't. More sun and more exercise,
just wherever you go. Yeah. So, I wish I had a dime for every time people ask questions like this,
because I feel so sad for them, because this is kind of the state of what's going on. People
are struggling because they're not getting answers. And again, I think you're not going to get
answers if you're not fighting somebody that's going to continue to ask the right questions. And I
do feel bad because a lot of people will contact us and say, I can't afford to run these labs.
I've spent all my money, and they spent their money on doing, getting promises like, oh, we're
going to just do IV vitamin C in personal ethics. Those are expensive things to do on a regular
basis, but you've got to dig to find the cause. So, when you go, okay, what can be some possible issues
with chronic overwhelming fatigue? Well, certainly post-COVID, chronic viruses, including COVID,
can be linked to that. You have tested against, you know,
no indications of infectious diseases. I'd like to see what labs that this person read.
Product fatigue. So, remember we talked about microglial priming and neurological functions.
That's something you always want to go back to, because it's fairly easy to know if something
has a cause in the periphery, or if something has a cause in what's called your upper motor neurons,
or let's say your brain is spinal cord. So, if your brain is at cause, the symptoms are going to be
a little bit more vague. So, put it this way. If I smash my toe and my toe is throbbing,
I know the cause was I smashed my toe and my toe has to heal. Now, the pain that I feel in my toe
is actually firing up my sensory neurons into my brain or the opposite side of my
right along my brain. That's where I actually feel the pain. But I know the cause because I know I
smashed my toe. But let's say I have a little bit more vague symptoms. My toe hurts at different times,
but sometimes it's not always my right toe. Sometimes it's my right knee, and sometimes it
things move around like we talked about before. It's just a little bit more vague. Then you start
thinking that it's more of an upper motor neuron. Is the inflammation actually in my brain?
When you got more obvious upper motor neuron issues like fatigue, chronic fatigue, what could my
chronic fatigue be? Well, years ago people would just go, it's probably your adreatals, you had a
adrenal insufficiency. Well, maybe that's it, but you can easily test for that. Doing a 24-hour
cortisol test and see your cortisol changes. Is it good testing DHA as well? Is it good test? To test
for that. I met people with serious chronic fatigue, serious emotional issues, serious
imbalances with mood issues, anxiety issues, but they have perfect cortisol balance. It's not their
adreatals. They don't have adrenal burnout. It's not their pituitary. Could it be something else
that's were digging to that in most people that are in that category have a serious gut inflammation.
And remember, if you have a Cyrex array 10 or a food sensitivity panel with a lot of things in
the red and yellow, that means you have serious gut inflammation. Rule number one, if you have gut
inflammation, you have brain inflammation. Then if you have brain inflammation, you could have the
biggest different types of symptoms that move around peripheral symptoms that move around
and or symptoms that are cubely connected to brain inflammation like fatigue or brain fog or
loss of, can't remember things or obvious brain inflammation issues. So, go back, again,
to go to our website, look up viral information and watch that video. I would, if you
have the ability financially to do some tests, I would get anybody testing again, array five,
an array seven X. That would be my go-to labs for a person with that thing's they have
chronic life like that other question before. A lot of people, again, like that they,
they attribute it to chronic life. This person's question, they're not, they're saying they've
investigated chronic life, they don't think they have it. Which truth is, is that if you've had
this chronic fatigue for over half your life, you may have had a chronic life incidence that
there's no presence of even the IgG antibodies anymore because it's been so long. It doesn't make a
difference what that initial cause was. Now we know the cause of your symptoms is either antibodies
to neural tissue or microglio primate and you have to address that. So remember, if you have
antibodies to neural tissue and or microglio primate, you're going to have symptoms based upon where
in the brain that is taking place. Now it's typically fairly diffused through the brain,
but you can have more inflammation at different parts of the brain. So one person can have more
motor neuron issues and have more, you know, issues with motor function.
A person can have issues with cerebellum. They have more inflammation than cerebellum. They've
made it coordination issues. Personally, they have issues with the phryanoloma. They're going to have
more sensory issues like pain and that moves around. It's sensory things that move around.
So again, asking the right questions. Digging it and doing the different tests that would be
appropriate. Again, if you need help with any of these and, you know, your finances are extremely
limited. I say spend $50 and join the chronic disease and autoimmune course. You can find that on
our website, cutterspletic.com, or if you want more specific help, feel free to self-schedule
and schedule a case review with me and I'll gladly help you work through these things.
That's really what my job is. It's trying to help you work through these things.
It's, you know, I don't have a magic ball that tells me what everybody's problem is,
but it's, you know, using the wisdom that you gained through, you know, increased knowledge and
increased experience. You are able to try to put people in the right direction. I'll just
try to do that the best way I can. So, and you can also go to cutterspletic.com. Again,
there's plenty of blog posts on a lot of this stuff that will help you too. Okay.
Next question. How long does it take for the right machine to cure an infection? Well,
the right machine is not always going to cure an infection, first of all. Can the right
machine really help with an infection, help with a virus, help with bacteria? Yes, it can. Can we
have cases where it's literally miraculous? But sometimes you need to take an antibiotic. Sometimes
you need to address, you know, the immune system in other ways. So, I highly cautious,
caution people to rely on one thing at any given time. I think the right machine should be at
everybody's house. I think that everybody should have a true right machine. Not just cancer patients,
but I think it could be beneficial for your kids, if you're unofficial for your families. I think
frequency medicine should be your first thing you go to. However, it's not a cure-all for everything.
It's not a magic fun. And things do take time. Even if you are using your properly diagnosed
it, then you are using the exact right frequency. It can still take time to heal. So,
that's why I have it at not going to a practitioner's office, I think it's much better.
Related question, can you use the right machine on your pets? Yes, you can. But again, you need
proper diagnosis, right? So, I mean, if you know, if you want your dog to the vet, the vet says
your dog has kidney cancer, you can definitely run kidney cancer frequencies for your dog,
it might have dramatic effects. If they say, if you know what's going on with your dog,
your dog has histamine issues and hives or something, you could certainly run the histamine program
side of your dog. Again, you really can't hurt yourself, running the right machine on anything.
The only thing I caution you about is running gram-negative bacteria programs,
like Borrelia for lying. Borrelia is a gram-negative bacteria. And it kills the bacteria and
can kill it and it can kill too quickly. When you kill a gram-negative bacteria too quickly,
you'll generate a lot of liquid polysaccharides and you could get a heart-send reaction. So,
that's the only thing I caution you about is if it is a gram-negative bacteria that you're suspecting
a K-A line would be the most common, you got to go slow because you don't want to
kill too quickly, you produce a lot of hidden toxins and you could feel lucky.
Next question is garlic, a good substitute for a blood thinner? Well, legally, I can't say that you
should change anything from a medical blood thinner if that's what you would prescribe. But
from a nutritional perspective, garlic is probably the strongest blood thinner
that exists from a nutritional dietary perspective. I would caution somebody who's
a lot of blood thinner, so that would be taking too much garlic. You could have too much blood
and some capillary fragility and easy bruising and things that's what you should be looking for.
Garlic is not only a natural blood thinner but it is a really good thing to kill infections
in the blood. People that have issues with bowel, heart valve issues which is not uncommon,
especially with people with cardio-legally and large carts of taking garlic could be
beneficial. So you have to be careful with this. Garlic is a TH1 stimulator, that means it's
an immune stimulator. So if you do have an autoimmune disease, you can't take garlic on a regular
basis anyhow. So it will be helping your body kill that which everybody's against, which is your
tissue. So you could use it for a short period of time. Like any immune stimulator, if you have
an autoimmune disease, it doesn't mean you can never take immune stimulators. You can cut it down
with cold or something, but you wouldn't take it long-term. I think that's about all we have time for
for our call today. Remember, go to holistic health power for all our past calls. We have all index
really nice holistic health power dot com. But that's where you could ask your questions,
which are the questions that came in other than the blog, the chat questions we were able to get to
today. Go to cuttersclinic.com. If you want to find out more information about us, you want to see all
our blog posts and videos we could write it on there and download the books and get our courses.
And full bloodshed. So all right, God bless. Everybody have a great day. See you next week.